In today's world, the first look at a superhero
costume can be the most important part of
building positive buzz - or having fans write
the project off completely.
The first look isn't always the final verdict,
whether it's a costume that brings the comic
book version to life, or changes it completely.
But sometimes, the fans' doubts are proven
to be a good sign - either that, or they never
know just how awful the reality of the costume
really was for the actor.
Here are the 10 Most Controversial Superhero
Movie Costumes of All Time.
Psylocke
Since her debut in Marvel Comics, the mutant
Psylocke's willingness to show some skin has
turned just as many heads as her psychic blade.
So when X-Men: Apocalypse put Olivia Munn
in basically the exact same outfit, some eyebrows
were raised.
Munn made sure the character's costume wasn't
just meant to get fans drooling, and with
the addition of some flesh-colored latex covering
the edgier areas, audiences can make decide
for themselves.
Captain America
Steve Rogers got a clever costume during his
World War II days, recreating the color scheme
and red and white stripes without actually
looking too silly.
But that changed with The Avengers, with Cap's
colorful mascot outfit justified by claiming
that the public might need a hero who was
old-fashioned, and a bit cheesy.
Fans were fine with it, since the movie itself
was a hit.
But the costumers clearly heard the criticism,
since every single Cap costume since has been
an update of the original style - basically
asking all of us to forget the Avengers look
ever happened.
Green Lantern
Almost every practical comic book costume
gets a little tweaking thanks to digital artists,
whether it's CG capes, added effects, or tech.
But with Green Lantern, director Martin Campbell
made a bold choice: to go with nothing practical,
and make the entire suit a digital creation.
The idea that the Green Lantern ring makes
the suit from pure energy IS faithful to the
comics, but the end result turned off almost
everyone - especially the mask.
And when your star actually HAS the body of
a comic book superhero, why waste it?
As an added bonus, Ryan Reynolds has claimed
that the mocap suit was so hot, it must have
been "made of actual woven misery."
Catwoman
From the first look at Halle Berry's Catwoman
costume, every moviegoer knew the movie was
going to be a disaster.
Aside from looking ridiculous in general,
the amount of skin being shown had critics
enraged, pointing out that the version of
Catwoman in Tim Burton's Batman Returns (Warner
Bros.) was actually MORE seductive, showing
no skin at all.
But it might just be a problem with the character
as a whole.
That incredible version worn by Michelle Pfeiffer?
The actress had to be vaccuum-sealed into
it.
Not only did she hate it by the time filming
wrapped, but over 60 versions of the suit
had to be made at $1,000 a piece.
Quicksilver
No movie superhero proved you can't judge
a book by its cover like Quicksilver in X-Men:
Days of Future Past (Fox).
Where the Marvel version of the character
(Avengers: Age of Ultron) stuck to the slick
style of the comics, Bryan Singer went...
a different direction.
The metallic jacket might have fit the 1970s
setting, but from the moment the silver wig
and goggles hit the Internet, fans went crazy,
claiming it to be the dumbest design of the
entire franchise.
Even actor Evan Peters wasn't sure it would
work, but the character wound up a fan-favorite
- goggles and all.
Batman
When director Joel Schumacher took over the
Batman series, he decided that the Dark Knight
needed some flare.
George Clooney's version takes most of the
heat, but it was actually Val Kilmer who first
showed off the infamous "Bat nipples."
The idea was to model the Batsuit after statues
of Greek gods, nipples, cod pieces, muscles
and all.
But by the time the sequel hit theaters, the
nipples and gratuitous butt shots had turned
DC's biggest hero into a walking punchline.
Wonder Woman
Having already teamed up with Batman and Superman,
and with a solo movie on the way, it's hard
to believe Wonder Woman was going to appear
on TV played by Adrienne Palicki, instead.
Enough people thought the pilot episode was
worthwhile to actually get it filmed, but
once fans caught sight of the new costume,
jaws dropped.
A reminder: this costume was designed in 2011.
Fans would have debated even a perfect Wonder
Woman costume, but the spandex pants and glittering
gold left no doubt: the pilot would wind up
not going to series, and basically embarrassing
everyone associated with it.
Batman
Christopher Nolan's take on Batman might be
seen as brilliant now, but following on the
heels of the Bat-nipple-suit, a Batsuit that
was actually practical and realistic seemed
like a risky move behind the scenes.
One by one, every feature of the suit, from
the grappling gun to the wings, had to be
justified - to the director, and in the movie.
For Christian Bale, the commitment to realism
meant he still couldn't turn his head while
in the suit, and the materials left with with
intense headaches.
Who knows?
Maybe that rage is what made Batman Begins
such a hit.
Harley Quinn
The Joker's girlfriend has usually courted
controversy with every one of her outfits,
showing more and more skin in cartoons, comics,
and video games every year.
With Dc's Suicide Squad, the filmmakers designed
a new look keeping her modern blue and red
color scheme intact - and sticking with the
short-shorts and stilettos, too.
Actress Margot Robbie mainly complained about
being soaking wet in just a t-shirt and shorts,
unlike her co-stars, but claimed the sexy
style was part of what made Harley tick.
Whether the audience will buy it... remains
to be seen.
Deadpool
We couldn't discuss some of the most hotly-criticized
superhero costumes without addressing the
mother of all mutant mistakes: Deadpool, from
X-Men Origins: Wolverine.
Even now, it's hard to know what the filmmakers
were thinking, giving Wade Wilson optic blasts,
retractable swords, and the ability to teleport
without even giving him a suit - or a mouth.
Ryan Reynolds got to set things right - and
then some - but there was a time when this
take on Deadpool seemed like it had killed
the character on film for good.
Those are the superhero costumes we remember
being the most explosive, controversial, or
just plain misguided.
But which ones have we missed?
Let us know in the comments, and remember
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one.